hong kong's top court has revoked bail
for media tycoon jimmy ly
the high-profile pro-democracy activist
is facing charges under new security
laws imposed by beijing he was released
on bail last week
but prosecutors argued he should be put
back in prison adrian brown's joining us
live
from hong kong adrian just bring us up
to date with what happened in court
today
well the imposing colonial era building
behind me rob has witnessed
lots of history during the past couple
of decades and we got another bit of
history today i think because
for the first time the court of appeal
here in hong kong the highest court in
the territory
basically ruled for the first time in a
case
involving the new national security law
that was imposed on hong kong
six months ago and in their 12-page
ruling the key section is paragraph 30
where they say that the
judge in the lower court erd when he
decided to release
jimmy ly eight days ago saying that that
decision
was invalid now a lot of legal experts
are saying that you know this decision
doesn't mark the end of
hong kong's judicial independence but
it's beginning to look
a little bit shaky we heard earlier on
today from mark daley from the
hong kong law society who said that you
know the judicial
system here had been stung by a number
of criticisms
that have come from state-controlled
media in china remember
state-controlled media speaks for the
government a few days ago the people's
daily said that
jimmy lie was was evil and dangerous and
in fact that his trial
should be held on the mainland and mark
daley says that
comments like that are really a direct
interference
in hong kong's independent legal system
and put undue
pressure on judges it's also emerged
rob that the three judges three
appeal court judges who ruled today are
also
on carrie lamb's approved list for
judges to
take part in national security cases
they include the chief justice
jeffrey marr and i think it's fair to
assume that carrie lam will be
happy with today's outcome as will her
political masters
in beijing adrian thank you very much
indeed that's adrian brown bringing us
up to date from hong kong
the case is being watched closely by
many in the region including in taiwan
which has welcomed hong kong dissidents
pro hong kong democracy activists there
have been voicing
their disagreement over the case against
jimmy lie
jimmy is not even guilty of anything the
charge of collusion with foreign forces
he is said to be guilty of is beyond
comprehension
if so every person who is here right now
anyone who watches tv is guilty
i want to make it simple if jimmy ly is
guilty then we are all guilty